willkommen zur aktuellen Vorlesung heute
wollen wir noch einen kleinen Nachtrag
geben zum Thema Ethik der Virtualität
der virtuellen Realität ich mache oben
rechts einen Link rein zu der gesamten
Vorlesung zu diesem Thema und wir
wollten uns noch die Frage nach dem
digitalen oder vielleicht auch
virtuellen bösen Stellen ich hatte
gesagt gestern dass digitale ist nicht
mit dem virtuellen gleichzusetzen es
gibt vieles was digital ist was auch
digitalisiert ist was nicht wird
aktualisiert ist dadurch zum Beispiel
bloße digitale Abbilder sind nach den
Begriffen die wir hier entwickelt haben
keine virtuellen Gegenstände
sondern virtuelle Gegenstände müssen
noch etwas eigenständiger sein und jetzt
kann man sich fragen
gibt es sowas wie
virtuelle Formen des Bösen natürlich
auch das guten oder das unmoralischen
und da möchte ich kurz auf Luciano
floridi eingehen ein Oxforder
informations Philosoph floridi
der hat eine Philosophie auf Information
geschrieben man sieht hier jetzt gleich
er wählt den Zugang nicht über das
digitale sondern über den Begriff der
Information er spricht von einer
sogenannten infosphäre eine infosphäre
umfasst die digitalisierten oder
digitalen Informationen aber auch
analoge Informationen also
Zeitungsinformationen alles was
irgendwie informationell vorliegt
natürlich ist der Informationsbegriff
ziemlich weit da kann irgendwie alles
runterfallen DNA enthält ja auch
Informationen müsste man jetzt kritisch
zurück fragen ob die Infos wäre auch
natürliche Informationen enthält
deswegen setze ich nicht hier in der
Vorlesung an den Begriff der
Informationen sondern am Begriff des
virtuellen
und jetzt hatte hier eine Tabelle
gebracht wo er eine Taxonomie von
Agenten und Akteuren bringt das wollen
wir uns jetzt mal ein bisschen anschauen
weil wir uns die Frage stellen wollen
gibt es virtuelle Akteure oder
Akteurinnen auch unabhängig von uns
Menschen vielleicht virtuelle Akteure
die nicht dasselbe sind wie aber tare
wir haben gesehen aber tare in
Metaversum können unter bestimmten
Umständen nicht nur als Simulation von
uns verstanden werden sind als virtuelle
Akteure weil sie anderen Raum zeitlichen
Bedingungen unterliegen mit schau mal
hin was er hier unterscheidet er spricht
hier von
naa das sind natürliche und autonome
Akteure zum Beispiel eine Person ein
Tier ein Engel Gott oder Außerirdische
das sind natürlich autonome Akteuren
erfasst natürlich den Handlungsbegriff
sehr weit auf dadurch kann er auch ein
Tier als Akteur fassen das kann man
natürlich kritisieren man kann ja auch
sagen ein Tier kann eigentlich gar nicht
handeln weil zum Handeln eine bestimmte
entwickelte Form von Vernunft gehört das
gehört zu gehören auch Gründe Tiere
können vielleicht gar keine Gründe für
etwas empfinden aufbringen abwägen er
hat also ein sehr weiten Begriff von
Akteur
n Hass das sind jetzt natürliche und
heteronome Akteure
also natürlich heißt eben nicht
künstlich so Gegenbegriff zum
künstlichen eine Flut ein Erdbeben und
einzunehmen so was fasst ihr als Akteure
ist natürlich wirklich durchaus
problematisch
auf der anderen Seite kann man sagen
wenn man von einem Erdbeben spricht dann
sagt man das Erdbeben hat das verursacht
und das Erdbeben kann auch irgendwie als
natürliches Ereignis abgegrenzt werden
von anderen Ereignissen ja eine Flut hat
eine kausale Kraft er orientiert sich
hier ganz klar der kausalen Kraft und
eine Flut tut etwas wenn man so will
Blut ertränkt Menschen alles Gute
zerstört Menschen also aber ein sehr
weiter Begriffen Akteur was uns jetzt
interessiert sind die AAA
artificial
Agent künstliche und autonome Akteure
ein webot ein Expertensystem ein
software-virus ein Roboter das
interessiert uns jetzt sind
also
autonomes agents wie Viren
können wir die auch virtuelle Akteure
nennen bitte etwas virtualisiert nach
unseren Begriffen naja wir müssen uns
fragen was ist der Zweck der Zweck ist
Schaden anzurichten
den Schaden können wir natürlich auch
direkt anrichten als Naas als natürliche
und autonome Akteurin aber ist jetzt ein
webad wirklich autonom setzt er sich
selbst Zwecke
das finde ich muss man etwas
problematisieren ein webad ist doch
programmiert also nicht autonomen
sondern die Gesetze die ihn bestimmen
die sein agieren wenn man so will
handeln möchte ich jetzt nicht sagen wir
kennen im Deutschen auch die
Unterscheidung zwischen agieren und
Handeln agieren ist irgendwie schwacher
vieles was agiert interagiert ist nicht
gleich als Handlung zu verstehen und der
Aktion gibt es auch zwischen Tieren oder
auch vielleicht sogar Wechselwirkungen
zwischen natürlichen Phänomenen also
reden wir lieber von Aktivitäten oder
Aktionen
vieles davon ist ja nicht jetzt
irgendwie autonomen sind die ist von
außen gekommen man sieht er hat auch ein
sehr weiten Begriff von Autonomie
wollen wir jetzt gleich darüber
diskutieren inwiefern ist jetzt ein
webad ein Akteur ein autonome Akteur und
vielleicht sogar auch ein virtueller
Akteur
und der unterscheidet noch
AHS das sind künstliche und heteronomen
Akteure
Verschmutzung Inflation und Stau
interessant also ich finde ich möchte
dich von vorne rein jetzt alles hier
abweisen sondern es ist nachdenkenswert
ein Stau eine Verschmutzung wie finden
ist die künstlich klar sie ist Menschen
gemacht ein Staues Menschen gemacht aber
wie finden ist der heteronom er
entwickelt nicht aus sich selbst heraus
eine Kausalität
natürlich sind auch Inflation und
Verschmutzung irgendwie kausalwirkst
worin unterscheiden die sich jetzt von
Roboter
das ist wirklich eine spannende Frage
man kann es sich so vorstellen
Inflationen entwickeln sich irgendwie
nicht nach klaren Regeln die haben
keinen klaren Antrieb auch
Verschmutzungen entwickelnde
Eigendynamik Kausalität ist enthalten
aber nicht so dass diese Dynamik im
Medizin gerichtet ist anders gesagt da
ist keine Teleologie enthalten keine
Zielrichtung das sind alles Aktivitäten
die künstlich erzeugt sind die eine
Kausalität haben aber die Kausalität ist
nicht auf ein konkretes Ziel gerichtet
während ein webot sehr klar Ziele
verfolgt sie muss man sich natürlich
fragen verfolgt er diese Ziele aus sich
selbst heraus weil er sich diese Ziele
selbst gesetzt hat und das möchte ich
bestreiten ich wäre jetzt hier kritisch
autonomen zu nennen weil sie sich nicht
selbst die Gesetze geben sie haben sie
von außen einprogrammiert bekommen aber
ihre Teleologie ihre Zielrichtung ist
auf jeden Fall klarer geordnet als die
von
Staus oder Verschmutzungen haben die
entwickeln auch eine Dynamik aber nicht
zielgerichtet das ist alles ein bisschen
die Fuß ihre diskutieren gleich drüber
ich gehe mal ich zeichne ja gerade noch
auf für diskutieren gleich weiter
darüber ich will noch kurz weitergehen
das dauert möchte ich kurz erwähnen weil
ja auch im Darknet
webbots unter Umständen zu finden sind
ja
Darknet die Schattenwelt des Internets
ich hatte die Frage aufgeworfen ist das
Darknet ein virtueller Handlungsraum
und zwar einer der
den virtuellen Handlungsraum auch ihr
verkleinert ich hatte ja gesagt
die Ethik der virtuellen Realität im
digitalen bemisst sich danach ob wir den
Handlungsraum für größern oder
verkleinern meine These wäre jetzt das
Darknet verkleinert den virtuellen
Handlungsraum obwohl man jetzt erstmal
denken könnte im Darknet sind mit Dinge
möglich die mir ja sonst im Internet gar
nicht möglich sind das vergrößert mein
Handlungsspielraum ich kann darin Dinge
kaufen erwerben wie ich sonst nicht egal
erwerben kann in atemberaubenden Tempo
entstehenden verborgenen Bereichen des
Internets blühende Schwarzmärkte
verlassen Drogen Medikamente falsche
Pässe geklaut die Kreditkarte oder
Hacker Dienst diese anonymen Online
Shops sind kundenfreundlich und nutze
orientiert bezahlt wird mit Bitcoin oder
anderen kryptowährungen hier sieht man
jetzt wir kommen jetzt verschiedene
Phänomene die wir schon diskutiert
hatten sprich digitale Objekte heute
werden
deep Web die Unterschied ist das Disc
clearweb ist das was sagen
indexiert ist was Sie mit Ihrer
Suchmaschine erreichen können das Dieb
Web das sind nicht indexierte Seiten
die können sie nicht gar nicht durch
Suchmaschinen erfinden ja und das
Problem ist im Internet das was sie
nicht finden können das existiert für
sie eigentlich gar nicht ja das wird
zumindest nicht ausgegeben ja ein
Riesenproblem und ich habe mir sagen
lassen bis die Web ist viel größer als
das clearweb ist natürlich immer
genauere Statistiken dazu bringen man
denkt immer das Internet sei all
dasjenige was man durchsuchmaschine
sichtbar machen kann oder verfügbar
machen kann so ist es aber nicht also
ganz komplexe Datenstruktur und jetzt
gibt's noch das Darknet und da kommen
sie nur mit einem Tor Browser nein eine
Orient Adresse dieses Zwiebelsystem
das da ist jetzt an sich ja noch nicht
irgendwie moralischen es kommt darauf an
was man darin macht ich möchte trotzdem
auf eine Hinweisen des Darknet entzieht
sich eben dieser sichtbaren Seite ja
es ist ein Schattenbereich eine
nebenwelt des Internets wo man teilweise
Passwort reinkommt und wo es natürlich
auch illegale Bereiche gibt aber schauen
Sie her
illegalen Bereiche gibt es natürlich
auch ein klebe
sie können natürlich auch durch
Suchmaschinen gebotene Inhalte
illegale Inhalte sich er Google suchen
ist möglich auch wenn immer wieder
versuchen unternommen werden diese
illegalen Inhalte dann auszublenden ja
ich darf nur ein Software Piraterie
erinnern ja mit etwas Suchanfragen
kriegen Sie das gewünschte die
gewünschte Datei da haben sie ein
Zugriff auf die gewünschte Datei das
häufig manipulierte Dateien gecrackte
Dateien an Dateien deren deren
Sicherheitsmechanismus durch geschicktes
hacking oder geschicktes programmieren
entfernt wurde sodass sie dafür nichts
bezahlen müssen das gibt es natürlich
auch im clearbe aber natürlich noch viel
deutlicher und auch noch viel
krimineller hier im Daten das Problem
was ich jetzt darin sehe aus ethischer
Sicht ist nicht das dass sie im Darknet
illegale Dinge tun können das können sie
nämlich auch im clearweb sind das
ethische Problem ist in meinen Augen
darin zu sehen dass das Darknet sich
abkapselt das ist die Tendenz hat
separate Bereiche zu eröffnen und so
stabilisieren und zu erweitern die nicht
mit dem clearbe verbunden sind und eine
Ethik des Internets oder ein echtes
virtuellen Handlungsraum sollte immer
berücksichtigen dass man sich darin
vernetzen können muss dass es
Sichtbarkeit geben muss anders gesagt
dass es so etwas wie eine Öffentlichkeit
geben muss kann spricht von einem
öffentlichen auch der Vernunft und der
ist im Darknet nicht möglich das kann
man natürlich sagen ein öffentlicher
Gebrauch der Vernunft der ist ja auch im
clearweb nicht unbedingt immer der Fall
das ist richtig weil wir häufig im
clearweb anonym oder pseudonym
Agieren der Unterschied ist jetzt doch
der zum Darknet das selbst wenn wir
einen quer nicht unterwegs sind unsere
Spuren sichtbar sind unsere Ergebnisse
vernetzbar sind und sozusagen zur der
liberativen Meinungsbildung die Jürgen
habermaß haben beitragen können das
können Dinge die sich der Öffentlichkeit
entziehen auch häufig unter dem
Deckmantel des Schutzes nicht man muss
jetzt dazu sagen dass Darknet hat ja
nicht nur negative Seiten viele Menschen
nutzen das weil sie nicht in bestimmten
Staaten ins Internet kommen weil das von
Regierungen verboten ist oder
eingeschränkt ist müssen den Weg über
starknet nehmen so könnte man immer
argumentieren dennoch scheint mir das
nicht die beste Option zu sein weil man
sich der Öffentlichkeit entzieht ne das
ist ein ein Entzug aus dem öffentlichen
Diskurs und das kann natürlich auch aus
ethischer Sicht problematisiert werden
wir kommen gleich zur Diskussion wenn
wir das Internet also als einen
virtuellen öffentlichen Handlungsraum
verstehen dann erscheint das Darknet als
ein abgekapselter schattenraum
stellt sie jetzt die Frage wie wenn eine
Abkapselung eines virtuellen
handlungsraums selbst eine unmoralischen
Raum eröffnet also nicht durch dasjenige
was man in dem Raum tut der Raum kann ja
nichts dafür was man ihnen tut das
Internet ist ja nicht deswegen schlecht
oder böse weil wir daher unmoralisches
tun können wir können ja genauso gut
Gutes darin tun sind das Problem ist
eher die Form die Struktur des Raumes
die Struktur des Internets des clearws
ist so dass es Vernetzungen zulässt ja
sogar fordert und fördern durch
hypertextuelle Verlinkung über
Textualität durch das Symbol Teil das
kennen sie in jedem Bürger mit heißen
diese drei Punkte oder die drei Striche
das ist das sogenannte bürgermenü und
Sie können eben
reibungslos unmittelbar Informationen
teilen auch wenn es unnötige
Informationen sind aber das Teilen an
sich ist eine Form von Öffentlichkeit
und man Erreichbarkeit und von
ja Orientierung trotz allem selbst Fake
News geben irgendwie Orientierung
abzuführen wir uns auf sie beziehen
können und sie in bestimmten Kontexten
teilen können davon Twitter erinnern wir
da Bezug genommen wird auf eine
Nachricht auf ein Posting dass einem
auch nicht gefällt so teilt man das auch
wenn es vielleicht falsch ist wenn es
eine Fake News ist aber es führt dazu
dass wir dann in einer Gemeinschaft
drüber diskutieren können und das geht
eben nicht im Darknet es ist keine
Öffentlichkeit das ist eine private zu
tun das ist in meinen Augen das geht
nicht um eigentlich ethisch
problematische und nicht das was man
darin tut weil man kann eben auch
urugalisches tun vielleicht nicht so
leicht ist also die Struktur würde ich
sagen
sind also alle virtuellen Handlungen die
im Darknet vollzogen werden als solche
bereits unmoralisch das muss man jetzt
diskutieren so weit würde ich jetzt
nicht gehen aber man muss sich schon
dessen Bewusstsein dass der Schritt ins
Darknet der Schritt aus der
Öffentlichkeit ist und dass das hier
nicht was man tut eben nicht öffentlich
mehr verhandelbar ist alles andere was
wir tun ist öffentlich verhandelbar weil
es durch Suchmaschinen prinzipiell
indexiert werden kann weil es sichtbar
ist erreichbar ist auch wenn es unsinnig
sagt wird auch Unsinn der vernetzbar ist
ist am Ende irgendwie sinnvoll und das
jenig ist eigentlich unsinnig was nicht
erreichbar ist was ich entzieht oder was
auch zu Blasenbildung führt ja das
möchte ich jetzt einfach mal hier so ein
bisschen zum Diskussion stellen wir
diskutieren darüber und dann geht es
gleich weiter mit der nächsten Thematik
nämlich mit der Ästhetik der virtuellen
Realität